ahora les pido que vayamos al año 1973
allí existía un personaje que ejercía un
liderazgo muy particular desde el bajo
perfil y la modestia este hombre era
parte de una generación que transformó
esta ciudad una generación que pensaba
en el largo plazo
una generación que entendía claramente
que nosotros es más importante que yo
este hombre decidió retar al gobierno a
que atendiera a su ciudadanía con
justicia y equidad y le salió muy caro
su asesinato
ese hombre era don eugenio garza sada mi
abuelo que ha sido fuente de inspiración
para mí y para muchos otros mexicanos
hoy les voy a platicar de quiénes somos
quiénes fuimos y quiénes podemos llegar
a ser
si nos paramos hoy en las calles de
monterrey digamos madera guerrero vamos
a ver una cantidad importante de casas
de empeño
casi una tras otra donde quedaron las
financieras que ayudaban a emprendedores
a iniciar sus negocios en las esquinas
vemos ninis jóvenes que ni estudian ni
trabajan nuestros abuelos jamás se
hubieran permitido eso
en los periódicos escuchamos
continuamente historias de
enriquecimiento ilícito o inexplicable
generalmente de políticos que se supone
que son servidores públicos
si analizamos el índice of work gaming
este que mide cómo las personas dedican
su tiempo o dinero al servicio social
nos damos cuenta que méxico está muy
lejos de 139 países evaluados méxico
ocupa el 106 solo venezuela y paraguay
están por debajo de méxico
e
pero no todo lo que vemos es malo
también vemos grandes avances económicos
en empresas en universidades
mucha gente que ahora tiene capacidad de
tener automóvil
sin embargo esto nos marca una clara
polarización
y aunque la polarización en sí es mala
lo verdaderamente preocupante es que
quienes viven en estas condiciones y no
nada más me refiero a los que tienen el
grande auge sino cualquiera que tiene
sus necesidades básicas resueltas parece
no darse cuenta de lo que está pasando
allá afuera se quedan en su mundo y no
se dan cuenta de la realidad que está
sucediendo allá afuera de los problemas
de inseguridad de falta de educación de
falta
problemas sociales
donde quedo
el sentido de lo que significa ser una
verdadera comunidad en qué momento se
nos olvidó que el éxito individual
requiere del bienestar colectivo
cómo llegamos a esto amerita una larga
reflexión
ahorita les quiero platicar del
monterrey industrioso s de nuestros
abuelos y bisabuelos
monterrey se funda en 1596
con un pequeño grupo de familias con
viviendas de palos lodo y sácate
el comienzo fue bastante difícil para
ellos el clima bastante complicado en
esta ciudad y continuos ataques de
indígenas les hacían la vida muy difícil
pero esto también fue forjando ese
carácter duro y fuerte del regiomontano
tuvieron que pasar casi 300 años para
que sus esfuerzos se vieran reflejados
en 1882 monterrey ya había logrado traer
el ferrocarril
en 1809 ochocientos noventa monterrey ya
tenía dos metalúrgicas las primeras en
todo latinoamérica y me brincó hasta el
43 cuando se funda el instituto del tec
de monterrey parece año monterrey ya era
una referencia a nivel internacional y
ese mismo año también nos visita el
magnate nelson rockefeller y queda
maravillado con lo que ve que está
pasando en esta ciudad y nos deja una
cita que dice el espíritu industrial
creado en méxico lo encabeza monterrey y
debe ser secundado por todos los países
el crecimiento de la población del 40 al
60 crecimos casi tres y media veces la
población
eso fue posible solamente porque habían
encontrado la receta del desarrollo
como lo hicieron
invertían sus ahorros
a sus hijos los mandaban a las mejores
escuelas del mundo traían extranjeros
para que participaran en las áreas que
no dominaban
pensaban en grande pensaban en el largo
plazo
y tenían una cultura que premiaba y
promovía el trabajo el ahorro la
honestidad y sobre todo la solidaridad
las condiciones de monterrey no eran
ideales ni para agricultura y ganadería
ni la minería que eran las industrias
del momento así que tuvieron que usar su
ingenio y encontraron la colaboración
incluso colaboraron con el gobierno
esta generación trabajó muy de cerca con
él lázaro garza ayala y muy particular
particularmente con bernard dos reyes
quien dio condiciones favorables
fiscales a quienes invirtieron en
puestos de trabajo
esta generación también a través de las
empresas de don eugenio fue la primera
en trabajar temas de previsión social
les dio salud a través de sociedad
cuauhtémoc y famosa les dio préstamos
para sus viviendas les dio también
también fue la primer generación que
generó fondos de ahorro para el retiro
una generación que entendió claramente
que nosotros es más importante que yo
las empresas ayudando a los trabajadores
las universidades a sus estudiantes el
gobierno a sus ciudadanos y las familias
a sus miembros
de chico me tocó tener la oportunidad de
asistir a campos de verano en los eeuu y
después de un par de años yo llegaba a
la conclusión que los mexicanos éramos
mucho más inteligentes que los
americanos no entendía cómo es que eeuu
era la primera potencia y nosotros no
logramos
fue muchos años después que me cayó el
veinte que nada tenía que ver con
inteligencia simplemente a ellos los
habían educado
a no romper las reglas por beneficios
personales
somos una sociedad
que está pensando en el beneficio
personal en vez del colectivo una
sociedad miope que no piensa en el largo
plazo
el beneficio duradero personal se
requiere también del colectivo y ya no
lo demostraron nuestros antepasados
siempre he pensado que si somos seres
sociales y como tal la empatía es algo
inherente entonces me pregunto por qué
batallamos tanto para demostrárselo a
nuestros semejantes
hoy somos una sociedad moderna que gira
alrededor de la gratificación
instantánea
pero también estamos como aletargados a
los estímulos pues son tanto los que
recibimos todos los días de las redes
sociales que nos hemos vuelto
insensibles a los sentimientos y aunque
estas redes sociales parecen el problema
creo que también son la solución pues
somos una sociedad que imita y repite
comportamientos y más cuando proviene de
líderes y ustedes cada uno de ustedes es
líder en el área en donde donde
participa también tenemos que invitar a
quienes más tienen pues como bien dice
el dicho a mayor poder mayor
responsabilidad
nos tenemos que convertir en una
sociedad verdaderamente crítica y
exigente una que quien no participe en
ayudar a la sociedad se sienta aislado
completamente aislado cuando hagamos
esto seremos una verdadera comunidad
responsable
quienes podríamos ser si analizamos lo
que ha pasado en los últimos diez años
si antes hay una cantidad muy importante
de organizaciones de la sociedad civil a
veces trabajando en distintos temas
alrededor de educación salud
por supuesto seguridad discapacidad
etcétera y no es casualidad que los
países más desarrollados y felices del
mundo son precisamente los que mayor
participación tienen en sus programas
sociales para darles un ejemplo los
estados unidos dedica el 2.1 por ciento
de su producto interno bruto en
donativos méxico llega apenas al punto 2
cuando analizas esto
das una idea porque en méxico ha
batallado tanto en salir adelante en ser
un país del primer mundo
tú
tú cuánto de tu tiempo o cuánto de tu
dinero dedicas tu empresario tu ama de
casa tu ejecutivo
cuanto de tu tiempo das
hoy te pido si eres de los que se queja
de lo que pasa en el país te preguntes
primero en cuanto a su organización a
organizaciones participas cuánto de tu
tiempo o dinero estás dando si no te has
dado cuenta de la desigualdad brutal que
existe allá afuera
te invito a que abra los ojos y veas lo
que está pasando afuera la problemática
de inseguridad la problemática social la
problemática de drogadicción
de disfuncionalidad de las familias
les quiero platicar de sara y las haré y
la conocí en mis oficinas con un grupo
de jóvenes que venían a presentarnos el
desarrollo de aplicaciones o apps que
habían estado trabajando con supera 111
que trabajan
con jóvenes en condiciones de
vulnerabilidad en este caso trabajando
en buscar cerrar la brecha digital entre
estas personas
era interesante escuchar como estos
jóvenes que estaban a punto de presentar
un plan de negocio a un grupo de
empresarios e inversionistas
evidentemente estaban nerviosos casi tan
nerviosos como estoy ahorita
el grupo de sara y fue de los de los más
destacados y de ahí se les pasó a dar
cursos de programación de inglés incluso
en la incubadora del tec de monterrey
participó que eso les permitió después
concursar a nivel nacional y ser
seleccionados para representar a méxico
en el sur de corea
en el día y con 2017 y trajeron el
tercer lugar
sara y nació y ha vivido toda su vida en
el polígono 51 uno de los polígonos que
agrupan las colonias
más desiguales marginadas e inseguras de
monterrey
sara y nació producto de un embarazo no
deseado
no ha conocido a su padre
ha tenido que vivir con sus abuelos pues
su madre tenía sólo 15 años cuando nació
aquí está consejo con su abuela
aquí es cuando regresaron y aquí es una
foto en el sur de corea
sara y ha decidido no ser parte de la
norma se ha entendido que con educación
cultura de legalidad y perseverancia se
puede llegar muy lejos
se me olvidó decirles estar ahí tenía 16
sólo 16 años cuando nos presentó las
aplicaciones hoy tiene ya 19 y cursa el
segundo semestre de ingeniería en la
universidad de nuevo león
sara y está con nosotros si te pones de
pie por favor solo ahí
muchas gracias y felicidades
ser parte de una historia como esta me
llena de orgullo y de satisfacción
hagamos muchas historias como los de
estar ahí seamos parte de la solución
las condiciones de hoy no son ideales
más bien diría yo pintan bastante
complicadas pero nuestros antepasados ya
nos enseñaron la receta tenemos que
trabajar en la colaboración los que
trabajar en ser socialmente responsables
tenemos que trabajar en formar
comunidades y tenemos que participar
con una participación social ciudadana
los invito a que seamos parte de la
solución
en monterrey
se tiene la frase trabajo y ahorro yo le
agregaría y solidaridad
hoy me invitaron a hablar de ser más yo
yo los invitaría
a ser más nosotros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]